for now though it's draft time big cat
we got rid of the coin toss we do the
trivia question now you ask me the
question today okay say Quan Barkley led
the NFL in yards from scrimmage last
year who is the last non running back to
lead the league in yards from scrimmage
the last non running back to lead the
league in yards from scrimmage I'd say
Calvin Johnson 2012
julio jones in 2015 Wow Wow but that's a
very obscure question like that are like
alright well you get first pick yeah
you're the football expert alright I'll
take the first pick I'll have the first
pick because there's only one first pick
when it comes to the biggest surprise
teams of all time I guarantee you had it
as your number one pick it is the 1999
st. Louis Rams Trent Green their
starting quarterback goes out for the
season in the preseason everyone says
who is this guy who's been bagging
groceries in Iowa they were four in 12
in 1998 the st. Louis Rams led by future
hall-of-famer he would didn't know he
was a hall-of-famer at the time he was
just a guy a backup quarterback Kurt
Warner and the st. Louis Rams the
greatest show on turf what an explosive
year what a crazy year to come out of
nowhere to have that happen to lose your
starter your starting quarterback who
everyone thought you know Trent green
this guy could do it in the preseason
and then win the Super Bowl and go
thirteen and three and destroy teams by
far the number one pick overall biggest
surprise team of all time I don't I
don't agree with you that it's by far
number one and it is on my list but you
know a similar dynamic played out just
two years later with the team that was 5
and 11 in 2000 with the team that and I
remember vividly I was listening to ESPN
radio on a Saturday Mel Kiper was
hosting with someone and Mel Kuiper's
said that looking at the 2001 schedule
of the New England Patriots he believes
they could be the first team in NFL
history to go Oh in 16 and it obviously
it turned out quite differently for the
Patriots fueled by Drew Bledsoe
suffering a serious injury at the
shoulder of molo Asst this sixth round
draft pick that nobody really was paying
any attention to from 2000 Tom Brady the
chance to come on and play they were 5
and 5 after 10 games they lost to the
st. Louis Rams during the regular season
somehow dug out of it somehow it all
fell together somehow beat the Raiders
in the snowglobe Tuck rule game
somehow went to Pittsburgh I was at that
game when the Patriots beat the Steelers
Brady got hurt during the game Drew
Bledsoe came in and finished it and
there was talk Bledsoe was going to
start the Super Bowl he expected he'd
start the Super Bowl they went back to
Brady and somehow they beat the greatest
show-offs on turf to win Super Bowl 36
the Patriots of 2001 the all-time
biggest surprise NFL team boom roasted
no it's not boom roasted because when I
made my pick you said audibly dammit
so I said yeah put I've given you a
false sense of security so you don't
work as hard to sell your case all right
you can't you can't my mind tricks on me
I do on you Mike let's just keep
leapfrogging
along NFL history you want to go 1999
Rams 2001 Patriots how about 2003
Carolina Panthers they didn't win a
Super Bowl but Jake Delhomme took a team
to the Super Bowl just let me say that
one more time so people understand what
I said
Jake Delhomme took a team to the Super
Bowl they were one in 15 two years prior
Mike they were seven and nine the year
before that team no one expected it John
Fox Jake Delhomme that team came out of
nowhere I'm taking the 2003 Carolina
Panthers there were three points away
from winning a Super Bowl that was an
all-time surprise team I am stunned that
you did not do the Jake Delhomme name in
chris burrman voice with the chris
burrman nickname I'm stunned
I'm disappointed what was it Jake Dell I
can't get a lice comb yes chica
daylight comes and I want to go home not
as good as John kit and kaboodle but
close okay you know that one wasn't on
my list so it must not have been a very
good pick or it would have been on my
list but but I'm gonna go back to the
same decade and even though this team
didn't make it to the Super Bowl the
2005 Saints were a disaster because of
Hurricane Katrina and they were playing
in San Antonio they were playing at LSU
and who
they have and what's going on and they
have a new coach and they get this
quarterback from the then San Diego
Chargers who had 27 studs in his
shoulder and and they don't know whether
or not Drew Brees is gonna be able to
play well they get the second overall
pick they they have Drew Brees fall to
them and it creates a ton of excitement
in New Orleans and then they start
playing the games they have that home
game against the Falcons the reopening
of the dome and I yeah it's fine but
once they start the game the Falcons are
gonna roll all over them you have the
Steve Gleason punt the next thing you
know the Saints under Sean Payton with
Drew Brees with Reggie Bush are in the
NFC Championship game against your
Chicago Bears and even though it
obviously didn't work out the way the
Saints would have wanted the fact that
they dug that franchise out of nothing
they dug that City out of one of the
worst catastrophes that any city has
ever suffered in the history of the
United States that was unexpected that
was a great story
and that's got to make the list okay I
like that pic I also that NFC
championship game that was maybe the
most perfect setting ever it looked like
Madden snow it looked like a snow globe
member that snow coming down and the
Bears beat the Saints in the NFC
Championship game in Chicago good pick
not a great pick but a good pick so I'm
gonna finish my dominant draft with a
little bit of a heavy hail I'm gonna
give you a little Juke here Mike my
third all-time surprise team in the NFL
is a team that went eight and eight a
team that didn't make the playoffs can
you name the team that I'm talking about
are you saying they're surprised because
they weren't good they were expected
right is that what you're doing you're
going the corrals and Washington
franchise is that were your the one I'm
going with the 2011 the most famous team
out there 2011 Eagles the dream team
they have made the playoffs three years
in a row everyone expected them to be
one of the best teams in the NFL they
had an unbelievable offense a year
before Vince Young says Dream Team they
make a big splash in the free agency
market they start four and eight Mike
they lost as 13-point favorites at home
to john skelton and the arizona
cardinals they ended up going
so they won their last four games which
I think even goes more to what I'm
talking about because they show that
they had it it just never came you know
it was they ran out of time so to speak
so I'm saying the one of the biggest
surprise teams a team everyone I
guarantee you had in the playoffs that
year didn't make the playoffs losses
13-point favorites fell on their face
the 2011 Dream Team Eagles I knew you
were gonna do one of those surprises in
a negative way and I really thought it
would be 2000 Washington because they
loaded up the cannon with Bruce Smith
and Deion Sanders and and basically
everyone was ready to hand them the
Super Bowl trophy before the season even
began and they failed to make the
playoffs I can't remember whether they
were eight and eight or worse than that
got Norv Turner fired and it was just a
horrible disappointment in Dan Snyder's
second year of ownership and it's been
one horrible disappointment after
another since then alright
ai-ai-ai-aight kind of hinted at this
pic earlier in the show when I talked
about that period of time a decade or so
ago when the trendy prediction for
analysts in the NFL was to say that the
Cardinals were gonna make the playoffs
because the Cardinals are do the
Cardinals are do the Cardinals are do
well in 2008 the Cardinals somehow made
it to the playoffs they somehow won the
NFC West and going into week 17 they
were eight and seven and they had lost
four of their last five games they were
falling apart they beat the Seahawks to
finish the year 9 and 7 and win the
division and then I remember people
saying that this is the worst team to
ever qualify for the NFL playoffs this
was before that year that the Seahawks
were sub 500 and still hosted a playoff
game the 9 and 7 2008 Cardinals everyone
was saying this team is horrible they
have no business being in the playoffs
they're gonna be out quickly and then
the Falcons lose to the Cardinals and
then the the Cardinals go to Carolina
and that was the night that jake
daylight come and me wanted Delhomme did
Delhomme for good with 6 interceptions
Larry Fitzgerald was out of his mind the
next week they beat the Eagles a team
that had blown the Cardinals off the
field on Thanksgiving night and then
they almost beat the Pittsburgh Steelers
in what would have
one of the most stunning and most
memorable superbowl outcomes of all time
it still is but not the way it would
have been if that larry fitzgerald shot
out of a cannon to the endzone would
have held up and that would have been
the winning points so the 2008 Arizona
Cardinals to come as close as they did
to winning the Super Bowl
after being derided by everyone at nine
and seven after losing four out of five
games down the stretch to get to the
Super Bowl and almost win it one of the
biggest surprises of all time and I
regret not drafting them higher and
thank you for leaving them for me with
the third round that's fine I just
searched I just did a little quick
google search I searched your 2011
preseason predictions
you picked the Eagles to win the
Superbowl the dream day I probably
didn't pick the Cardinals to make the
playoffs in 2008 so well the easy didn't
make the playoffs in 2011 the only other
one I had on the list that uh that I was
thinking about picking was actually the
2017 Eagles with Nick Foles being the
quarterback that one just missed the
mark there so the day obviously when I
remember when Carson Wentz went down in
LA and everyone said this season is over
and even Nick Foles in that first
playoff game wasn't great and then he
went on an unbelievable magical run and
they beat the Patriots with the backup
quarterback 2017 Eagles would be my just
missed the list I had them on the list
as well it was kind of a weird one
because they were wire-to-wire one seed
until Carson Wentz gets injured but then
it does become a surprise because they
were the underdog in every home game
they remained a dog in every game of the
postseason and ended up winning the
Super Bowl I also have the 1969 Jets how
can you put the 1969 Jets on the list
how can you not be how can you not write
well we didn't but we at least we
mentioned them Joe Namath you got your
mention today alright big cats got the
99 Rams 2003 Panthers 2011 Eagles I got
the 2001 Patriots 2006 Saints 2008
Cardinals I win he loses that's okay
he'll get over
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports